oui
[Musique]
à l'issue des élections internes des
républicains j'ai voulu mettre en place
une équipe à la fois resserrée mais très
ancré sur le territoire faire rentrer
beaucoup d'élus locaux parce que la
réalité notre vie quotidienne c'est sur
les territoires est aussi beaucoup plus
ouverte sur la société civile
je veux mettre en place des forums
professionnels et socio professionnelles
les représentants de la vie associative
les corps intermédiaires qui ont été si
souvent humiliés méprisés par le pouvoir
en place en toute leur place au sein des
républicains et façon avoir
effectivement cette ouverture à la fois
sur le monde mais aussi sur ce qui fait
la vie quotidienne de nos territoires en
s'adressant à tous les français sur tous
les sujets notre vocation républicain ce
n'est pas d'être seulement un parti
d'opposition
mais c'est surtout d'incarner
l'alternance l'alternance ma chronique
ça ne peut pas être le rassemblement
national et l'alternance rassemblement
national ça ne peut pas être le
maquereau nist il y a une force de
droite qui doit émerger c'est celle là
que nous voulons incarner les
républicains ne reprendront leur place
deux grands partis de droite populaire
et ouvert que s'ils renouent avec la
promesse du rassemblement la volonté qui
nous anime aujourd'hui avec cette
nouvelle équipe c'est celle du
rassemblement c'est celle de la
réconciliation mais aussi faire cesser
toutes ces guerres d'ego qui nous ont
bien souvent conduit à la défaite est
plutôt que les guerres d'ego engageons
nous dans cette proximité et cette
humilité
les français ont besoin de voir une
classe politique proche d'eux humble
respectueuse et au travail
notre premier grand rendez-vous sera
celui des élections municipales
j'y mettrai toute mon énergie tout mon
engagement pour démontrer que la
crédibilité de l'action sur les
territoires c'est nous c'est les
républicains la droite gagne
lorsqu'elle est rassemblée lorsqu'elle
est unie et à l'occasion de ces
municipales nous devons faire la
démonstration de cette capacité à nous
rassembler cette capacité à nous unir et
faire valoir nos valeurs de droit c'est
cette alternance que nous devons
incarner
[Musique]